if you look at ethics for one most
people's sense of value and what's
important to them and how to act comes
from their religious tradition or from
some philosophical perspective that they
may have gained through humanistically
not necessarily religiously but from
their family or the community so it's
it's natural it seems to me to have that
as part of what you're doing in your
work life because that's how you
ultimately operate when the chips are
down when you're being asked to be
honest when you see things that are
going on that are wrong your religion
really is there behind you I think for
your spirituality but in other ways too
just to find times in the day when you
can relax when you can pull back from
all the stress of work
spirituality especially through
meditation prayer other modalities like
that is a way for you to again find
what's really important find your
essence in the midst of a very busy day
if you're constantly busy if you're
constantly going going going
you really do first of all start making
mistakes you don't have perspective you
don't have the vision that you often
need strategically to think about you're
working about the firm as a whole and
where it fits in industry and in society
and you get tired out I think it's a
back and forth that's as the Taoist
tradition would say a yin and yang you
want to go back from moments of quiet
and stillness to times of being very
busy and very productive and you'll do
better in terms of integrating yourself
as a whole being but also you would be
doing better in your workplace my
parents used to tell me there's two
things you should never talk about in
public especially over dinner with
friends and that's religion and politics
so I think that's right people are
worried about where religion may lead
it's very deep it's very powerful it can
be very divisive there's terrible things
that are done in the name of religion
and are currently being done in the name
of religion so there's lots of reasons
to be leery of it in the book that I
wrote with Laura Nash Harvard Business
School we look at three kinds of
religion what we call espoused religion
catalytic religion and foundational
religion and by spouse religion we do
mean the dogmas and the doctrines and
the teachings of a particular tradition
and often those traditions like with
Christianity or with Islam are
proselytizing and converting traditions
and we think it's not appropriate to
bring that to the workplace but
catalytic religion by which we mean
these methodologies and meditation and
prayer and things that can be personally
sustaining and what you can do honestly
in private you know you can close your
own door go out outside by yourself you
don't have to be seen doing that if that
doesn't feel cool and then there's
foundational religion and by that we
mean the great stories sagas rules that
we all kind of agree with like the
golden rule or the Ten Commandments
those you can usually
into the workplace and even note that
they come from sources like the Hebrew
Bible or something and not have that be
problematic for people if you're gonna
do business globally it really does move
you to know what the religious tradition
is that's primary within that tradition
or several tradition several religious
traditions may be there within that
country so if you're doing business in
Egypt it does but who you didn't know
something about Islam if you're doing
business in India something about
Hinduism and so on because so much of
the business climate in terms of its
etiquette its the ethos the cultural
ethos of a business does depend on the
underlying religion which is often
hidden from view but if you know
something about it you know it'll help
you a lot one example of how somebody
does bring their religion and their
morality through their religion to work
is Noah's Bagels the CEO of that firm
who also started bread and circus it
became part of Whole Foods the natural
food store he insisted because of his
Jewish commitments that the store closed
one day a week on the Sabbath and be
completely closed even though that would
affect the business and their capability
to have another day of selling bagels
and more employment for the employees
etc and he also brought other kinds of
ways of thinking to the work he's
referred to as a business mensch as a
you know an honest really caring
nurturing employer and that comes out of
his Jewish understanding you look at
somebody like Phil Jackson the coach of
the Lakers the LA Lakers and the Chicago
Bulls basketball teams and he brought a
Zen Buddhist understanding to his
coaching and has written a couple of
books about that very very explicit
about how Buddhism affected the way he
coached how he brought his team together
as a unit
a tional techniques that he is for and
visualization techniques for his team so
you know there's another example of
somebody doing that and staying with
Buddhism for a moment the CEO of
LinkedIn here in Silicon Valley Jeff
Weiner has written and spoken about the
importance of Buddhism in his management
compassionate management he thinks is
the the most important way to think
about doing business and he's been very
affected by the Dalai Lama over the
years and so he tries to think of
LinkedIn as a as a company that's run on
Buddhist principles but not in a way
that would be proselytizing or demanding
that people become Buddhists but
ultimately he would like to have spread
that notion of compassionate management
worldwide